tout de suite eh bien on va prendre à
nouveau la direction assez clemenceau
pour une autre édition qui s'est tenue
dans le cadre de cette même commission
denquête celle de marisol touraine la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé qui a également été entendu hier
soir au sénat
la pollution de l'air est désormais bien
identifié comme un enjeu majeur de santé
publique
ses conséquences sanitaires sont
mesurables et d'ailleurs mesurer cette
pollution est à l'origine d'une
augmentation préoccupante des affections
respiratoires et cardiovasculaires les
jeunes enfants les personnes âgées les
personnes souffrant de pathologies
chroniques sont particulièrement
vulnérables
mais la pollution concerne également
l'intérieur des bâtiments et on a trop
souvent tendance à l'oublier
nous passons près de 80 % de notre temps
dans des lieux clos
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
rappelle que plus de la moitié des décès
liés à la pollution sont dus à la
pollution intérieure
nous avons donc fait le choix de nous
engager en matière de prévention pour ce
qui est de l'air intérieur et j'aurai
l'occasion d'évoquer notamment la
prévention pour ce qui est du radon mais
j'y viendrai dans un instant la
pollution de l'air aux présente un
triple coup pour notre société un coût
sanitaire un coût social et un coût
économique
les études scientifiques sont unanimes
et l'organisation mondiale de la santé
le rappelle régulièrement la pollution
de l'air est le principal risque
environnemental pour la santé dans le
monde plus de 80 % des européens
seraient exposés à des niveaux de
particules supérieurs à ceux préconisés
pour la qualité de l'air émis par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
toutes celles et ceux qui sont
quotidiennement exposés les risques sont
réels
la pollution est responsable de
pathologies respiratoires telles que
l'asthme la bronchite la pneumopathie
mais aussi d'effets cardiovasculaires
art comme les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux et les cardiopathies d'autres
effets inquiétants ont été plus
récemment mises en évidence je pense aux
effets indésirables sur la grossesse sur
le développement neurologique et la
fonction cognitive ou encore sur
certaines pathologies chroniques comme
le diabète le coût social de la
pollution est préoccupant puisque les
populations qui en sont victimes sont
d'abord par exclusivement mais d'abord
celles qui vivent dans des situations de
précarité
les disparités en termes d'exposition
des populations sont constatables la
pollution de l'air est plus forte près
des grands axes routiers et dans des
secteurs particulièrement exposées
notamment à des facteurs industriels or
nous savons que les logements qui sont
situées dans ces zones sont
principalement des logements moins
coûteux et ce qui veut dire que les
inégalités environnementales viennent
aussi renforcer les inégalités sociales
enfin au delà du coût sanitaire le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
est considérable ces conséquences
indirectes sont sans doute les plus
difficiles à estimer
et elle varie selon les critères et les
chiffrages retenue mais plusieurs études
sérieuses ont d'ores et déjà permis de
l'identifier en pointant notamment le
coût des journées d'activités restreinte
qui lui sont liés nous devons donc
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens
face à la pollution de l'air et pour
cela le gouvernement porte une action
qui s'appuie sur différents leviers
j'ai en ce qui me concerne veiller à ce
que la prise en compte des conséquences
sanitaires de la pollution de l'air qui
a une place renforcée dans la politique
gouvernementale
j'ai ainsi augmenter le financement des
programmes de terrain ces financements
se chiffrait à 1 million d'euros en 2012
je les ai portés à un million trois cent
vingt mille euros en 2015
dans le contexte de maîtrise des
dépenses que nous connaissons la
règlement
tension de la qualité de l'air relèvent
du code de l'environnement et donc du
ministère chargé de l'écologie
mais ce gouvernement a su développer une
très forte coopération
interministérielle
ainsi le dispositif interministériel de
gestion des pics de pollution a été
complètement revu en 2014 pour tirer les
enseignements des épisodes de pollution
précédent ce dispositif autorise
désormais les préfets à prendre des
mesures permettant de réduire les
émissions
je les compléter par un plan d'action
sanitaire impliquant les agences
régionales de santé
ce plan préconise des recommandations
sanitaires à l'attention des personnes
sensibles et du grand public et instaure
une surveillance sanitaire lors du
dépassement des seuils d'alert je
souhaite ainsi informer les populations
sur les risques et détecter le plus tôt
possible tout impact sanitaire
éventuelle d'un épisode de pollution
atmosphérique
par ailleurs à l'issue du pic de
pollution de cette année 2015
nous avons engagées avec le ministère de
l'écologie le ministère
de l'intérieur une mission auprès
mission d'inspection sur la gestion des
épisodes de pollution dont le rapport
doit nous être rendu le 14 juillet
prochain en lien avec les ministères
chargés de l'écologie de l'agriculture
du travail et de la recherche
nous avons élaboré en novembre 2014 le
troisième plan national en santé
environnement qui courent sur la période
2015 2019 ce plan définit des actions
concrètes pour réduire les inégalités
environnementales et territorial de
santé
il contient de nouvelles initiatives en
direction des populations exposées à
plusieurs facteurs de risque dans le
cadre de la mise en oeuvre de ce plan je
porterai dans les prochains mois une
initiative nouvelle pour un urbanisme
favorables à la santé il s'agit
d'encourager les initiatives pour
dessiner une ville générant moins de
pollution et encourageant les
déplacements respectueux de la santé et
de l'environnement
avec le projet de loi de modernisation
de notre système de santé auquel vous
avez fait référence monsieur le
président nous franchirons une nouvelle
étape en matière de santé
environnementale
ce texte a été adopté en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale en
avril dernier et sera examiné par votre
axe par votre assemblée dans les
prochaines semaines son chapitre iv du
titre 1 vise à mieux informer mieux
protéger nos concitoyens face aux
risques sanitaires liés à
l'environnement
l'article 10 en l'état actuel du texte
vient ainsi modifier le code de
l'environnement s'agissant de
l'information faite au grand public
concrètement cette information ne se
limitera plus aux seuls effets sur la
santé de la pollution de l'air mais sera
élargie à l'ensemble des risques
sanitaires les impacts de la pollution
s'agissant notamment du nombre
d'hospitalisations et de décès seront
ainsi communiqué
en toute transparence le projet de loi
permet par ailleurs de renforcer la
lutte contre le radon je l'évoquais qui
figure parmi les polluants de l'air
intérieur les plus nocifs pour la santé
ce gaz radioactif d'origine naturelle
reconnu cancérogène certain et je veux
rappeler qu'il est le second facteur de
risque de cancer du poumon après le
tabac sera désormais intégré au
dispositif existant dans le code de
l'environnement avec un niveau de
référence défini enfin le texte
modernise la définition de moteurs de
notre politique de santé et comprendra
une identification des risques
s'appuyant sur le contexte d'exposer dom
c'est bien l'ensemble des expositions y
compris donc par inhalation qui sera
désormais prise en compte
c'est une avancée majeure qui était
particulièrement attendu par les
associations troisième levée levier
d'action l'international parce que nous
savons bien que la pollution ne s'arrête
pas aux frontières et que notre
engagement doit s'inscrire dans une
dynamique européenne et internationale
la quatrième réunion de haut niveau du
programme paneuropéen sur les transports
la santé et l'environnement s'est tenu à
paris en 2014
à cette occasion les 56 états membres
ont adopté une déclaration de paris qui
fixe les objectifs à atteindre d'ici
2020 pour des transports terrestres plus
respectueux de la santé et de
l'environnement
j'ai également porté ce combat dans le
cadre des travaux de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
la dernière assemblée mondiale de la
santé a adopté le 26 mai dernier une
résolution sur la pollution de l'air
et la santé c'est un message fort qui a
été adressé par cette résolution que
j'ai fortement soutenue et que la france
a coparrainé les états membres
s'engagent à améliorer la surveillance
de toutes les maladies liées à la
pollution de l'air à promouvoir des
technologies et des combustibles propres
et enfin à intégrer les problèmes de
santé dans toutes les politiques
nationales régionales et locales
relatives à la pollution de l'air agir
pour protéger la santé face à la
pollution de l'air est un engagement de
long terme et le gouvernement a donc la
volonté d'amplifier son action et
d'ouvrir de nouveaux chantiers
il nous faudra d'abord renforcer notre
expertise sanitaire
ce sera la mission de la nouvelle agence
nationale de santé publique dont la
création est prévue par le projet de loi
de modernisation de notre système de
santé
cet établissement d'excellence au
service de la santé des français verra
le jour en 2016
les travaux menés dans le cadre du
programme de surveillance air climat
coordonné par lyon vs l'institut
national de veille sanitaire seront
poursuivis et amplifiés
il s'agit de parvenir à quantifier les
impacts de la pollution de l'air sur la
santé et de mieux évaluer les impacts
sanitaires des mesures prises pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air
l'observatoire de la qualité de l'air
intérieur et l'homme cesse poursuivront
leurs travaux sur la connaissance des
expositions de la population et les
risques associés aux polluants de l'air
intérieur dans la continuité des études
conduites depuis plus de dix ans
ces travaux contribuent à construire une
réglementation notamment en matière
d'étiquetage des produits de
construction et d'ameublement
je souhaite par ailleurs que nous
modernisons l'information sur la
pollution de l'air l'information en
direction du grand public d'abord les
épisodes que nous avons connue au
printemps 2014 et 2015 ont mis en
évidence la nécessité de renforcer les
mesures d'information concernant les
risques liés à la pollution
atmosphérique l'information à
destination des professionnels de santé
ensuite ils sont directement sollicité
par le par leurs patients dès lors que
sévissent des épisodes de pollution
j'ai donc souhaité qu'un travail soit
engagé avec eux pour élaborer de
nouveaux outils adaptés
les premiers éléments de communication
seront disponibles à leur égard à la fin
de l'année
la recherche française en matière de
santé environnementale doit par ailleurs
être renforcée
le programme national de recherche
environnement santé travail conduit par
l'homme cesse devra être l'occasion de
mieux analyser les risques
environnementaux pour la santé humaine
enfin je souhaite que nous donnions la
capacité collective de donner à la santé
une place plus importante dans les
décisions internationales en matière de
climat la fin de l'année 2015 en france
fera bien sûr marqué par la 21e
conférence des parties de la convention
cadre des nations unies sur le
changement climatique
la coop 21 la santé devra tenir une
place majeure dans cette mobilisation
collective en faveur du climat
je travaille donc actuellement à la
préparation de ce rendez vous
j'adorais déjà organisé à paris avec
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les 13 et 19 juin dernier un colloque
international climat santé inégalités
quelles solutions dont l'objectif était
d'établir des décisions et
recommandations en termes de santé et
d'environnement pour qu'elle soit portée
au coeur de la coop 21 monsieur le
président madame la rapporteure madame
la sénatrice la recherche a
considérablement fait progresser notre
connaissance des impacts sanitaires de
la pollution de l'air
l'engagement du gouvernement pour mieux
prévenir et mieux accompagner
et total et mobilise l'ensemble des
départements ministériels le ministère
de la santé il prend bien évidemment
complètement sa part je vous remercie
je suis maintenant à votre disposition
pour répondre aux questions que vous
souhaiterez madrid nous vous remercions
de même madame la ministre dans tout
l'état pour eux ces propos introductif
qui balaie largement le sujet mais sans
plus tarder comme je vous l'avais
annoncé je vais passer la parole à notre
collègue rapporteur madame aïchi merci
madame la ministre de votre exposé un
propos liminaire donc depuis 1983 et les
premières études de l' oms nous avons la
certitude et nous savons que la
pollution de l'air est particulièrement
le diesel sont responsables de 50 mille
décès prématuré en france chaque année
de la pure fiction et de l'aggravation
de nombreuses maladies telles que des
cancers du poumon ou encore de la vessie
des maladies cardiovasculaires les
maladies respiratoires asthme bronchite
développement déficient des poumons des
enfants de nombreuses allergies de
l'apparition d'irritation oculaire et
d'inflammation des muqueuses de facteur
d'accroissement de problèmes de
fertilité des risques de malformations
congénitales et de mortalité infantile
de facteurs d'affaiblissement du système
immunitaire de facteurs d'augmentation
des taux d'hospitalisation des études
d'ailleurs extrêmement sérieuses
démontrent aussi le lien entre la
pollution des relais maladie de
parkinson et d'alzheimer et très
récemment des études viennent de
démontrer le lien qui existe entre la
pollution de l'air et l'obésité
madame la ministre nous avons je crois
le même diagnostic au travers de plus de
1000 études dans le monde qui confiant
ce qui vient d'être listé depuis à peu
près une trentaine d'années madame la
ministre je crois comprendre que la
pollution de l'air est un sujet qui vous
préoccupe pour autant qu'elle l'a été
dans le cadre de vos activités comment
vous êtes-vous mobilisés par exemple
pour l'interdiction du diesel puisqu'on
sait depuis 1983 que le diesel est
cancérigène
première question qu'elle a été
également l'action concrètement du
ministère de la santé pour
l'interdiction des pesticides et
particulièrement du glyphosate du
glyphosate
le ministère at il lancé des alertes
pour prévenir des dangers de seconde ce
qui constitue les les 7,7
cet impact sanitaire selon vous le
gouvernement dutil maintenir son
interdiction des feux de cheminée en ile
de france justement pour contrer les
émissions puisque son trait pourvoyeur
de de pm10 enfin quels sont les études
épidémiologiques lancé par le ministère
ces cinq dernières années si vous me
permettez pour rebondir sur des éléments
que vous avez soulevé vous préciser je
voulais petit rajoute une petite
correction sasy pa 2000 études dans le
monde mais deux cent mille études dans
le monde qui est temps qu'ils ont été
faites pour justement évalué l'impact
sanitaire de la pollution de l'air vous
dit à juste titre qu'il faut faire en
sorte que le ministère met en place tout
un système pour mieux informer nos
concitoyens face aux risques dus aux
risques sanitaires de la pollution de
l'air pour assurer plus de transparence
alors je me permets de vous dire chiche
madame la ministre
quid de l'action de groupe justement
pour pouvoir contrer le un certain
nombre de de pollueurs pour aller
justement dans le sens d'une
amélioration delà de la qualité de l'air
que nous respirons tous je vous remercie
madame ministre
oui mesdames la rapporteur sur la
pollution de l'air avant d'en venir aux
questions précises que vous avez posé je
tiens à vous rappeler que lors de
l'épisode de pollution de 2014 7 en
particulier sur la base des
recommandations sanitaires que j'ai fait
valoir que des mesures ont été prises
pour la circulation alternée
à l'occasion d'une journée puisque nous
avions constaté en 2014 beaucoup moins
en 2015 pour des raisons que je
n'identifie pas spécifiquement mais nous
avions identifié une augmentation
significative de la fréquentation dans
les services d'urgence pour des
consultations
manifestement liés à la pollution en
tout cas lié à des enjeux des problèmes
respiratoires ou des problèmes d'astres
donc respiratoires pour ce qui est de la
question du diesel
c'est un débat qui est ancien c'est un
débat difficile je ne répondrai que pour
ce qui relève de mon département
ministériel
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que l'on ne
pouvait pas ignorer la place qu'occupait
le diesel dans la pollution
atmosphérique et je les fais de manière
publique y compris dans sur les ondes
pour autant peut-on considérer que du
jour au lendemain il sera possible de
procéder à l'interruption l'interdiction
du diesel outre que cela ne relève pas
de mes compétences je crois que cela
n'est pas envisageable et donc j'imagine
que les ministres compétents vous ont
indiqué les mesures qui sont envisagées
pour faire en sorte de réduire les
émanations de diesel
excusez-moi de vous interrompre a même
admis on sait depuis 1983 que le diesel
est cancérigène ça fait plus 32 ans
s'agit pas d'abord d'assurer une
transition du jour au lendemain
est ce que justement n'a pas été
déficient pour justement anticipé le
problème le problème du dlc constamment
la réponse qui nous est fait et je ne
vous cache pas qu'à titre personnel ça
commence à être un petit peu agaçant
simplement il y a déjà quinze ans on
avait on sait puisqu'il ya des
procédures qui ont été faites justement
pour dénoncer le côté nocifs du diesel
nous avons dix youn et un certain nombre
d'autres
deux constructeurs automobiles qui nous
ont expliqué que le renouvellement moyen
d'une voiture ses 8,5 ans ça fait 15 ans
donc déjà en 15 ans n'aurait pu
renouveler deux fois la voiture est ce
qu'une bonne fois pour toutes on va
avoir des pouvoirs publics dynamique qui
vont une bonne fois pour toutes
aller dans un sens justement peut-être
de l'interdiction du diesel ça fait 32
ans que le discours s'agit pas de dire
que c'est du jour au lendemain trente
deux ans on anticipe à et on est
toujours dans cette rhétorique qui
consiste à dire qu'on ne peut pas
assurer pour des raisons pour des
raisons économiques qui vous aura pas
échappé puisque c'est des études que vos
collègues nous ont donné il ya un
déficit il ya à peu près un coup
simplement par la pollution de l'air
intérieur à 20 à 30 milliards d'euros
la pollution de l'air à un coût
sanitaire mais pas seulement un coût
environnemental est ce que justement il
est patent de profiter de cette
contrainte environnementale pour penser
à un saut un saut de changement
peut-être de deux modèles de modèle
économique puisque de toute manière
l'aps le l'impact sanitaire est avéré
une fait absolument l'objet d'aucune
contestation
et tout à l'heure j'ai relevé enfin je
vous ai précisé don il ya plus de cent
mille études dans le monde qui atteste
de cet impact et on est toujours dans
cette rhétorique serait environnement
qui consiste à dire qu'on va pas changer
du jour au lendemain ça fait quand même
madame la ministre
trente deux ans qu'on sait que le diesel
est cancérigène j'entends vos propos
manaa rapporteur je vous répondrais ceci
je suis ministre depuis trois ans et non
pas depuis 32 ans
la deuxième chose que je voudrais porter
à votre attention sans esprit de
polémique c'est qu'il y a moins de 32
ans il ya environ quinzaine d'années des
aides à la fin des années 90 et je crois
savoir que des ministres écologistes
étaient aux responsabilité des actions
ont été prises pour encourager l'achat
de véhicules diesel au motif qu' il
était plus intéressant au regard du
réchauffement climatique
il ne m'appartient pas de porter de
jugement rétroactif sur ses
préconisations
pour le reste je ne peux que vous
répétez ce que je vous ai dit je suis
ministre en charge de la santé
et comme ministre en charge de la santé
j'ai indiqué que le diesel avec
évidemment un impact sur la santé et que
nous devions en tenir compte
le dr grills oui merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
rappelé les chiffres et le coût
financier mais aussi le coût humain de
la pollution atmosphérique des coûts
tangibles et des coûts intangibles
nous avons lors d'auditions précédente
entendu donc des rapports sur les
conséquences de la pollution due aux
pesticides en particulier pour les
exploitants agricoles pour les
viticulteurs votre ministère at il
évalué l'impact de cette pollution
viala aimé ça par exemple une deuxième
question vous avez mentionné tout à
l'heure le travail en collaboration que
vous faites avec d'autres ministères je
voudrais savoir si des actions sont
menées entre votre ministère et missa de
l'éducation nationale afin de travailler
en amont d'engager des actions de
prévention mais aussi de modifier les
comportements des enfants qui sont les
futurs consommateurs et sous quelle
forme
enfin je ferais allusion à un incident
particulier qu'a connue donc je suis
sénatrice de seine maritime dans la
région de rouen qui a connu donc cette
région donc il ya trois quatre ans ainsi
dans lubrizol incident chimique avec des
rejets dans l'atmosphère
cette époque l'alertent avait été
insuffisante et les conséquences
sanitaires ne nous avait pas été
communiqué si un tel incident se
reproduise et aujourd'hui pouvez-vous
nous garantir que les conséquences sur
la santé seraient communiqués sur merci
pour ce qui est des études toute une
série
d'études sont engagés soit directement
par la direction générale de la santé
soit à la demande de la direction
générale de la santé et d'autres
ministères le plus souvent par land
fesses sur les sujets que vous avez
évoquées nous avons eliane vs ou par les
nvr et nous avons ainsi un réseau de
surveillance nous avons mené ou fait
mener des études sur les pesticides dont
j'ai eu l'occasion d'ailleurs de rendre
compte dans le cadre d'une mission
parlementaire qui a été réalisé si ma
mémoire est bonne en 2012 fin de l'année
2012 par votre par le sénat par des
sénateurs il des études ont été menées
sur les perturbateurs endocriniens qui
d'ailleurs se poursuivre
qui ont d'ores et déjà donné lieu à des
décisions en particulier dans le cadre
de textes de lois qui sont adoptées pour
l'interdiction de certains perturbateurs
endocriniens et ses études se
poursuivent et la france d'ailleurs est
un des pays qui est comment dire à
l'avant-garde entre guillemets en tout
cas qui a le leadership pour les études
au niveau européen en ce qui concerne
les perturbateurs endocriniens
pour ce qui est des pesticides dont je
vous ai dit que des études ont été
menées que des études se poursuivent qui
amène incontestablement à des signaux
d'alerté qui sont adressés aux
populations qui sont directement au
contact de ses herbicides en particulier
les agriculteurs bien entendu mais aussi
les particuliers qui souvent utilisent
de manière excessive est à considérer
des arbitres idée j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer il n'y a pas si longtemps en
disant que au fond pour un particulier
avoir quelques herbes qui poussent entre
des dalles ou dans un jardin de façon un
peu disons folle comme on dit des herbes
folles ça n'était pas forcément
désagréable et que l'on pouvait
parfaitement l'accepter et le tolérer
qu'il valait mieux cela que des
expositions aux herbicides pour ce qui
est de la question que vous posez sur
l'accident qui s'est produit en seine
maritime
en tout cas la volonté qui est la mienne
est de faire en sorte que les la
transparence soit absolue la
transparence est pour moi une ligne de
conduite que j'ai adopté dans tous les
domaines sanitaire
qu'il s'agisse et pas simplement pour ce
qui est des risques environnementaux
donc il me semble que pour ce qui est de
l'impact environnemental sur la santé
nous devons adopter les mêmes règles et
il y a un retard mais nous devons
adopter les mêmes règles que celles que
nous mettons en place pour d'autres
facteurs de risque sanitaire je pense à
des facteurs de risques de nature
extrêmement diverses qui jusqu'à
récemment faisait l'objet de
communication peu transparente et dont
j'ai souhaité pour ma part la
transparence qu'il s'agisse de
l'utilisation de certains médicaments de
certains produits de certains
dispositifs médicaux ou de l'apparition
de germes dans des environnements fermés
je pense par exemple à guise hôpitaux
dans lesquelles nous avons eu à gérer
des incidents
ou des accidents sanitaires qui ont été
totalement rendus publics
madame la ministre l'impact direct de la
pollution de l'air sur les dépenses
notamment de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie des travailleurs
salariés mais également sur la branche
accidents du travail maladies
professionnelles du régime général je ne
parle pour l'instant que du régime
général se situe selon les estimations
entre deux à trois milliards d'euros par
an parallèlement aux actions de
prévention ne pensez vous pas qu'il le
serait conforme notamment aux principes
souvent avancé pollueur payeur de
recouvrer tout ou partie de ces sommes
auprès de ceux on va dire qu'ils
émettent des polluants dans l'air par
ailleurs madame la ministre
j'évoque les régime obligatoire de
sécurité sociale ou en tout cas et
également je crois des régimes
il faut associer les régimes
complémentaires pensez vous qu'il puisse
être mise à contribution dans tous les
cas de par leur légitimité pour
participer aux côtés des régimes
obligatoires et régimes complémentaires
à l'identification des pathologies liées
au phénomène de pollution de l'air si
oui de quelle manière je dirais un suivi
en tous les cas les études pourrait-elle
être conduites pour avoir une meilleure
connaissance une meilleure appréciation
et pour tout dire pour éviter que les
organismes des régions est obligatoire
comme les régimes complémentaires ne
soit dans ce domaine d'ailleurs comme
dans d'autre que trop de payeurs
aveugles
la question que vous posez monsieur le
président est une question difficile
parce que elle renvoie c'est pour ça
qu'on la pose
oui mais je vais vous répondre quand je
dis difficile je ne veux pas que la
réponse est nécessairement difficile
mais moi je veux vous dire que certaines
des réponses qui pourrait apporter
serait en contradiction complète avec
les principes de la sécurité sociale
nous avons un système de sécurité
sociale qui si je peux répondre madame
là
rapporteur je vous dis ce qu'est ma
position je comprends que vous soyez en
désaccord avec moi mais avant même que
je me sois exprimé ça me paraît
peut-être un peu osée dont qui vous
permettait que j'apporte ma réponse la
sécurité sociale en france repose sur le
fait d'une prise en charge qui ne prend
pas compte ou ne tient pas compte des
causes des pathologies qui sont soignés
et donc nous avons des études qui
doivent permettre de comprendre
l'évolution des pathologies en france
nous avons des programmes de prévention
qui sont destinés à modifier les
comportements individuels ou collectifs
pour faire en sorte que ces
comportements soient plus favorables à
la santé par exemple
nous encourageons nos concitoyens à ne
pas fumer mais nous prenons en charge
intégralement un cancer du poumon d'un
de nos concitoyens donc nous ne disons
pas que ce concitoyens parce qu'il a
fumé est responsable de sa maladie et
donc nous ne le prendrions pas en compte
donc nous n'identifions pas dans la
prise en charge des pathologies
le facteur déclenchant de la pathologie
ce qui n'exclut pas que nous soyons
amenés pour comprendre les maladies que
nous soignons a mené toute une série
d'études et donc je suis extrêmement
attentive à maintenir une ligne rouge
extrêmement identifiées entre ce qui
relève du lance de la connaissance de la
connaissance pour favoriser la
prévention de la connaissance pour
améliorer les comportements individuels
ou collectifs mais en aucun cas je
les serait utilisé ces éléments de
connaissance pour modifier les
mécanismes de prise en charge soit par
l'assurance maladie soit par les
organismes complémentaires
pardon pardon à la mairie de vous
interrompre mais dans ma question soit
gelée mal formulé soit elle a été mal
comprise mais à aucun moment
à aucun moment je n'ai évoqué ces
questions de la prise en charge
j'ai évoqué la question quelque part de
la perception de la découverte et
notamment des phénomènes d'épidémie vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure un élément
qui va d'ailleurs complètement dans le
sens c'est le phénomène de pollution en
vous avez constaté un phénomène soudain
un accroissement sensible de
consultation et dont vous avez pris des
mesures
écoutez je pense en tous les cas qu'il
ait de bonnes eux - dirais-je simplement
de bon sens que de profiter de ces
phénomènes et ensuite de regarder de
quelle manière
1 on peut mieux répondre à la demande et
2 puisqu'il ya un lien une corrélation
avec certains phénomènes de pollution de
quelle manière l'ensemble des acteurs
par des études qui peuvent être des
études épidémiologiques m'est égal
voilà voilà non mais je ne je ne mets
pas en doute monsieur le président le
fait que vous à titre personnel en enjeu
même au titre de la commission denquête
ne souhaitiez pas remettre en cause ses
mécanismes de prise en charge
je ne dis pas que je ne je ne voulais un
put pas mais je suis obligé de constater
que des expressions qui vont dans ce
sens dans notre société se sont fait
jour et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je j'attire votre attention sur
le fait qu' une dérive est toujours
possible
il ya d'ailleurs des pays dans lesquels
ces analyses là se font et où on demande
aux patients d'avoir des engagements et
ce sont des organismes privés
d'assurances privées de prise en charge
qui conditionne la prise en charge de
leurs patients au respect d'un certain
j'entends bien mais est donc ce que je
dis c'est que nous devons
être toujours attentif et que pour
autant la connaissance doit se faire
dans le projet de loi de modernisation
de notre système de santé l'article 47
prévoit la mise à disposition des
données issues de la sécurité sociale et
des données épidémiologiques
c'est ce qu'on appelle article sur
l'opendata s'est donnés sont aujourd'hui
exclusivement réservé à la sécurité
sociale puisqu'elle ne sont pas ouvertes
elles seront dès lors que la loi sera
votée que les dispositifs de mise en
oeuvre seront adoptées c'est à dire
assez rapidement elles pourront être
dans un certain nombre avec des règles
définies une mise à disposition
d'acteurs publics ou privés à
destination de la recherche et donc des
études pourront être menées pour
notamment avoir des éléments plus précis
sur des relations de cause à effet entre
certaines situation environnementale
puisque c'est le sujet dont nous parlons
mais pas exclusivement et certaines
pathologies à faire des liens entre
certains types de traitements et
certaines pathologies et donc nous
faisons en sorte que les données soient
mises à disposition pour favoriser ses
programmes de recherche par ailleurs lee
nv est élancé ce méli nvs surtout amener
à travers son réseau de veille sanitaire
toute une série d'études surveillance de
l'impact sanitaire de la pollution de
l'air ces études sont connues elles sont
mises à disposition c'est par exemple le
programme clean air force europe de
l'union européenne ou d'autres
programmes et ces programmes doivent
nous permettre encore une fois d'alerté
de faire connaître à la population les
risques et de peser autant que faire se
peut sur les comportements encore une
fois individuel et collectif mais je
faillirait à ma responsabilité
en tout cas telle que je la conçois de
ministre de la santé et des affaires
sociales
six jeunes alertait pas sur les risques
de dérives
dès lors que l'on mettrait en avant
d'autres mécanismes de prise en charge
encore une fois je ne
vous fait pas le procès d'avoir cette
démarche là mais je suis obligé de
constater que certains mettent en avant
ses perspectives d'accord je veux vous
redire je dirais avec une douce fermeté
qu'à aucun moment aucun membre de cette
commission n'a évoqué cette possibilité
simplement je peux également vous dire
que hall on le dirait des dernières
années les gouvernants successifs et
notamment lorsque a été établi le
principe des contrats responsables des
efforts significatifs sont faits pour la
prévention et pour être bon sur la
prévention il fouette il faut aussi bien
maîtrisé
je dirai le moment des épisodes de forte
augmentation de certaines pathologies
donc je crois pour ma part à la
conjugaison des efforts des organismes
des régimes obligatoires et les régimes
complémentaires parce que woods
ils répondent l'un et l'autre dans
l'esprit de la sécurité sociale de 1946
à la même préoccupation
il n'y répondent pas de la même manière
dans la même comment dirais-je dans le
traitement notamment comptables mais
c'est exactement la même logique dont je
ne fais pas de procès et je ferme la
jeudi à la parenthèse sur ce sujet par
contre madame la ministre je ne vous ai
pas entendu me répondre sur les actions
de prévention est le principe éventuel
pollueur payeur ce sont des principes
c'est oui c'est non c'est peut-être le
chantier est ouvert voilà merci
le principe pollueur payeur supposerait
que l'on soit à même d'identifier
individuellement les émetteurs de
pollution ce qui va pas de soi il est
par ailleurs difficile d'identifier les
responsables de la pollution intérieure
dans les dommages
dire si on prend une personne porteuse
de pathologie il sera pas forcément
facile de faire la différence entre les
facteurs extérieurs et les facteurs de
pollution intérieure qui sont tout à
fait important pour autant j'ai moi même
saisi le haut conseil pour le
financement de la protection sociale en
lui demandant de réfléchir à des
facteurs complémentaires de financement
de notre protection sociale en indiquant
que non pas des mécanismes qui peut
pollueur payeur mais de taxation
environnementale pourrait être examinée
comme apportant un financement
complémentaire et non pas substitutif
aux cotisations sociales mais
complémentaires le gronder par le
ministre en charge du budget non mais je
dis ça peut être examiné l'impact
l'impact sur le financement de la
protection sociale stricto sensu
n'apparaît pas suffisamment stable pour
être identifiée comme une mesure pérenne
de financement puisque par définition
l'objectif est que les causes à ce
moment-là disparaissent c'est ce que
nous voyons est d'ailleurs un rapport de
votre assemblée sur les taxations
comportementale a émis des réserves sur
l'utilisation de ces mécanismes
mais ce sont des éléments qui peuvent
dans le cadre de l'évolution du
financement de la protection sociale
faire l'objet de discussions de débats
de propositions tout en ayant conscience
en tout cas selon moi que cela ne peut
représenter si l'on se place du point de
vue financier qu'un apport marginal par
rapport aux recettes de la sécurité
sociale
voilà pour cette audition de marisol
touraine la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé qui a donc été
auditionné par les sénateurs de la
commission d' enquête sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air on le sait cette pollution ne
l'est à la fois un désastre sanitaire et
économique sanitaire parce que 50000
français environ moore chaque année à
cause de cette poule
sion vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de la qualité
parlementaires à 16h30 pour la séance je
vous retrouve on parlera de la réforme
du dialogue social très bonne journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires